activities designed to help Young Minds
come to terms with
war children with very different
experiences but all suffering some
degree of trauma like 17-year-old
Valeria forcibly relocated to Russia by
her father then brought back to Ukraine
by her
mother earlier everyone would say that
we were one nation one people but it's
not true it's another country and when I
came back to Ukraine I realized I was
the one part of the country that's about
the least touched by War the Carpathian
Mountains are the perfect place for
recovery but many of the staff are
themselves from cities ravaged by War
such as psychologist ulia for
marup the trauma of war is
multi-dimensional and it's not just the
fear they experienced from the bombing
it's the fear of occupation the fear of
losing loved ones separation many
especially younger children such as
12-year-old cillo struggled to talk
about their
experiences we were taken in two buses
he tells us to a camp in Russia where we
stayed for a bit over a month but that's
about all he can
recount 17-year-old yevin was in the
same group and remembers the joy of
returning
home when we got home my first emotions
were meeting my friends and family again
there was joy and
warmth Ukraine has estimates about
20,000 children have been forcibly
relocated to Russia since the start of
the full-scale invasion nearly 2 years
ago despite repeated efforts and
international mediation only about 400
children have been returned the forced
removal has led to war crimes charges
against Moscow allegations that keev
hopes will one day reach an
international court for now the focus is
on reclaiming Ukrainian children and
helping them recover McBride aljazera
zachar Patia region
Ukraine make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler